americans have had enough of liberal
media bias and the press praising joe
biden while attacking republicans at
every turn
a new poll shows overwhelming distrust
just 16 percent of americans have
confidence in what they hear from tv
news
and you have to assume it's because of
examples like this
this was the swab that the nurse was
actually using
on you and disappeared so that in scale
this was the actual swab that was being
used you're like the holy spirit you are
all places people would be foolish to
underestimate michael avenatti michael
avenatti is a beast
okay that's true congress is the only
major institution that is trusted
less so we have that go up for us right
exactly all right so greg gutfold
yes president biden has received less
negative coverage than any president in
30 years according to pew
now contrast that with president trump
who received
press coverage that was 90 percent
negative no wonder everyone
just trusts the media well it's not a
surprise
it's not a surprise that the the bias
only goes in one direction the problem
is that
it can't be fixed i think it's done
because
they have embraced the sunk cost of
their past there's no way that cnn can
change their mentality
they've been anti-cop for a decade right
and now we're seeing it all play out on
the streets
they can't admit it they the only time
they ever admitted it was when they said
well this could affect joe biden
politically but they didn't actually say
you know what we really screwed up
uh the only way to sense how the media
works is if you become
the topic right can i use an analogy
it's like it's like there's a web let's
say there's a national website
that you put your name in and it tells
you your body weight right and so you
put your name in and you put in your
body and your body weight comes out and
it's completely wrong
you know that's inaccurate but nobody
else does that's how the media is able
to survive
the only people that understand the
fakeness of the media are the people who
suddenly become the subject matter the
moment you
are in an article and they're talking
about you
you go my god this is a scam and a sham
and they only want to hurt you
totally and jessica the argument that in
any way that this is defensible it sort
of flies out the window when you see to
like
the amount of coverage and what it went
down to so for example when it goes down
into the mundane
so remember when we killed kosum
solomani and cnn reported it as
that president trump was enjoying his
ice cream like his two scoops of ice
cream when he learned about the
airstrike
they sort of found a way in covering
everything to insert
a negative slant i've seen the studies
obviously from the trump administration
and
i would never deny that the press corps
is having an easier time with the biden
administration
part of that is joe biden doesn't hate
the press and president trump hated the
press and campaigned on it
he's also a liberal why would you hate
the press if you were a democrat
well i think that you can have a healthy
relationship with the press as a
democrat where you question each other
where you respect the fourth estate
and you don't call them fake news and
then you can get along and
still be pushed and joe biden has been
pushed on a number of the decisions that
he's made and better earn respect
jessica there's
there's no way anybody on the right
should respect the media
after 40 years since the 60s
here's how the media presses joe budden
because i went to soul cycle i barely
had it
okay did you heard it this is a long
time ago you could take that hr
wow
but this is a long time trend as greg
talks about on both sides and liberals
sit around and they don't trust
conservative media if you look at
something like the edelman trust
barometer that's been measuring this for
a very long time
this is where it's going and people are
looking to private institutions
you know private sector companies to
make up the difference because they
don't like congress they don't like
their representatives and they don't
trust the information that's being fed
to them and it's
it's really dangerous and it's sad
because there are a lot of people doing
fantastic work out there
conservative media is new it's like for
the conservative meeting arose because
of this imbalance
and now they're mad that conservative
media is beating the crap
out of them right and to that point
there's a 19
difference between republicans and
democrats who have high confidence in
broadcast tv news
that's why the respect is not there at
all because it has to be earned
democrats don't trust conservative media
because democrats don't watch
conservative media my mom is watching we
have to watch my mom
we have to watch all the left-wing
garbage all day that's why we don't
trust it
i have made this analogy and it's so
good i had a friend that
whenever he met somebody he assumed that
person was a sexual predator
right and then he worked back from that
assumption right so whenever i see
anything in the mainstream media
i assume it's wrong and then i work back
from that assumption
everybody else should do that because as
you said this has been a long time
coming what was it
was it the wmd's in iraq was it the duke
lacrosse case
was it the dossier was it the lab leak
was it the laptop from hell
was it kavanaugh was it smollette was it
cuomo was a hero and desantis was a zero
where's the q-tip
where is the q-tip yeah you know what
greg we have to launch an investigation
anybody out there that has access to the
q-tips send it our way
all right fine people hoax yeah rape
hoax
avenatti i mean the list goes on and on
and what's different now
in the age of information jessica is
that we have
access to everything that the mainstream
media
just used to have access to so we see
the numbers
we see the depositions we're now seeing
fisa applications
and it's all we even see the polling
internals for the first time
and it's just eye-opening how we've been
lied to
and yet even though we have all this
information the mainstream media
continues to lie to us
so greg's right you step on a scale
you're 85 and they can tell you
continue to tell you you're 105. who's
85 pounds
okay you guys might not know i like to
look on the bright side of things
i keep it positive i loved that inside
this there were also good numbers the
only industry that actually
gained favorability was police
what does that tell you after being
denigrated all year by the mainstream
media exactly their approval went up
and the one that lost the most public
schools
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else